mi hija y Abraham es consultor para
empresas locales que quieren abrirse al
mercado europeo para él la entrada a
Europa significaría prosperidad
económica y reducción de la tasa
desempleord es una oportunidad para
entrar en mercados más grandes Pero
tenemos obligaciones y responsabilidades
que cumplir ante Europa
no todos los moldavos se apuestan por el
cambio hay parte de la sociedad que
reticente al giro hacia Europa no veo
nada bueno en la entrada a la Unión
Europea nuestra economía cada vez va
peor solo causará más inestabilidad
y Ucrania han recibido el estatuto de
candidato para ingresar en la Unión
Europea y esto ha puesto a esta pequeña
República soviética en el punto de mira
de Rusia la población moldaba se siente
dividida por aquellos que temen la
represarias de Rusia y aquellos que
desean a toda Costa ingresar en Europa
las aspiraciones de moldavia ser parte
de la Unión Europea empiezan a sentirse
como una realidad que ha puesto al
gobierno de Natalia gabrielitza a
trabajar duro para lograr sus objetivos
ha decidido seguir el camino hacia
Europa después del 24 de febrero el
mensaje ha sido claro unirse al mundo
democrático o a la tiranía de Rusia
años de apoyo a gobiernos perrusos y
casos abiertos de corrupción han puesto
al expresidente moldavo y gordodón bajo
arresto domiciliario pero desde el
partido socialista se sigue trabajando
para cambiar la percepción sobre Rusia
única solución
para moldavia es permanecer neutral Ya
teníamos buenas relaciones con Europa y
debemos seguir manteniendo las con el
este Especialmente con Rusia solo hacía
Habrá Paz
con el temor a que la guerra cruce las
fronteras moldavia camina hacia un
futuro incierto marcado por la decisión
de elegir a Europa sufrir las
consecuencias de seguir alineado con
Rusia